all right the next store is a stop and
uh this is the one that we went to last
time and it was a fan favorite dare i
say because it's quite visually
appealing yeah uh it's really cool
really interesting store
tons of figures and you really do have
to look yeah so i hope you guys spent a
lot of money or bought a lot of figures
i know i bought quite a lot for you yeah
i think i bought like in terms of pure
number um
i think it's either a stop or army army
i bought the most figures i
actually didn't buy a lot oh really okay
so first of all what were your
challenges okay so my two challenges
were
uh mine was one to buy a female figure
and two to bide a lewd figure which is
great pretty easy so i could get two
figures in one and i guess i'll start
off
sure i think
my figure first i believe this is it
um so i actually like this was this was
the first time that i actually tried to
be tactical about what i bought okay um
for once in your life yeah in russian
once again you know we had riaz like
last year and this time we came in for
the clutch yeah this time we had the
figure where you know what it didn't
matter i it didn't matter about the game
i just followed my heart
all right so
this was the lewd figure that i bought
um so mudan gets ready to censor this
because i'm not sure i can't remember
how loud it is i don't think it's hentai
level loot
but it is definitely lewds
um
oh and it is that girl
from
i can't remember
oh it's from um
no no no it's a
boring girlfriend uh what's oh cycano
psychonauts yeah that's the one uh so
yeah it's that girl from cycling yeah do
you want me to point this towards the
camera uh the reason the reason there's
a lot of panty the reasons
there is there's a lot of people a lot
of panty and from one angle it's safe
and i mean she's uh she's not putting on
thigh highs but she is putting on her
socks right and so the reason i bought
this one was because it was a female
figure
it was
a lewd figure and
it was very very close to 420 i'm not
gonna reveal how much this was okay okay
just because i know you two bought some
other ones but uh yeah well we'll reveal
those at the end but i will say it is
close to 420. oh okay so that's that's
around the price for that yeah
what what did go into the mahogany wood
what's going on here kind of stuff is
pretty expensive icon itself is pretty
expensive and i'm not sure why like i
feel like
i i was surprised that this one cost
this much right it's just like weirdly
popular in japan for some reason i don't
know why but like i decided to i have no
idea why yeah i decided to go for it
because i couldn't like looking back i
couldn't find many figures that were
close to the 420 mark yeah so i like i i
saw this one i was like this one's
close-ish so let's just go for this one
and see where it takes right right
my ones were uh the first one was get a
fist of the north star figure which was
perfect because this is not stars like
one of my favorite manga series of all
time you were so lucky to get this one
in um a stop because you would have any
other star would have been [ __ ] if
you're like it's maybe like a stop and
maybe mandarakey
and uh
no way because we chose this one because
we know we knew it could be completed if
like the right circumstances were made
exactly but like because it's such an
old series it's rare to find yeah any
figures this is rare in general to find
anything fizzling all-star related yeah
yeah but i got one you asked did you
actually hell yeah i did god [ __ ] not
only that i i got a twofer ladies and
gentlemen i got a two for one two for
one i got two for one i not only got my
boy kenshiro but i also got
da or as well as a combo set look at
that oh my god how much were they
these yeah these were uh if i remember
correctly it wasn't actually that
expensive this one
uh these were
i think
a hundred and forty eight dollars oh
together
together it's actually not bad at all
actually i think no no no no i think
this was actually the cheapest one i
think this was 25 dollars
that's pretty cool yeah for for a two i
mean you know these are like kind of i
mean they weren't in box for one yeah
but it was a two for one so you you
line it up like that that's pretty sick
hell yeah boys the boys are back in town
let's go
i'll just show one off yeah yeah go for
it i got
pretty cool looking
oh nice oh okay from like the 90s ova oh
yeah oh
i've never really seen i love the dangly
bits actually yeah i've never seen it it
looks 90s yeah
that looks vintage i went freaks i
wanted more jojo figures because i think
i didn't get enough last time and i
wanted more on the set and i thought
this is really [ __ ] cool because it
must have been modeled after the old 90s
when that came out because like jojo
doesn't use a [ __ ] scarf thing in the
in the new one no i'm so glad i didn't
get any jojo figures because otherwise
i'd be losing points left and right
right now i'm glad you didn't get joseph
but also why does he look more like
lupin
oh a little bit
a little bit yeah yeah i mean i just
figured sick i think it was um not that
much as well correctly the problem with
a stop is that you can't actually see
which ones they work that's right yeah
so i have to remember we don't know how
much it works yeah i have to remember
i remember this one was quite cheap it
was like two thousand four thousand no
more than that like okay yeah pretty
good uh what else did you have gone yeah
so after i got uh after i've completed
as many challenges as i could i
basically just you know oh this also
completes one of my challenges but so do
many of my figures which is get a
character from a show and protect easy
i did what any guy would do and just
start collecting waifus um
very admirable i respect that i got
echidna from uh re-zero season two
i got her school uniform one which is uh
why why because the kid is great this is
cute
bro oh dude she's so cute what the [ __ ]
bro come on um of course i got a cheesy
root figure so i couldn't actually find
many cheese
i couldn't actually find many cheeses
does this count as a funko pop
i just i just wanted to buy one rent a
girlfriend figure because i couldn't
actually find many and i couldn't find
any reason yeah i couldn't find many of
chizuru so i don't know if there was
like if not enough had been made uh
these were pretty cheap were about in
the ten dollar range yeah i could tell
yeah
um
and i mean you know you know i just uh i
just wanted to pump pump the figure
numbers up with uh some girls that
hadn't been on the uh shelf yet so uh
i bought uh two other ones that weren't
a challenge so the first one i got was
mitsuha from kimino noah ah okay [ __ ] i
didn't see that one yeah and because one
of the challenges is get a figure that
is from an anime movie original yeah so
that's one point for me this was
actually the most expensive this was
258. was that wait was it get the most
anime figures from the movie original or
was it no no just one i think oh i
thought we had that challenge
was it the most
you should double check i'm pretty sure
get the most and i think there's one
from an anime original movie oh wait it
was get one from yeah
there's two movie challenges right
uh
oh yeah most figures bought from an
anime original movie
what have they done to
you oh my god
well i figured you know it was going to
be kind of difficult to find figures of
anime original movies because they are
quite rare i mean the fact that this is
258 says that this is pretty rare why is
it so expensive because i've i
personally have never seen a young man
before i've never i didn't even know
they made your name mean either
if we do if we're doing anime original
figures i will pick up my other one sure
uh i got a promo figure oh nice uh only
one
yeah only one uh this one i got a pretty
decent price if this one was i saw that
i thought it was quite expensive i
actually because i saw two one was
pretty expensive and one was i actually
have both the these and hindroids from
uh premiere actually they're really nice
uh how much is this one oh this one was
uh 59. that's not too bad yeah
which like i feel like anime original
figures are hard to find uh so they're
normally like pretty expensive
all right
what did you get connor
i also got another jojo figure because
this one was sick okay how many jojo
figures did you find
that one is good though that one i
actually saw that one i really like it i
just lost the point and so did you
oh did you get a dear or jonathan no
oh wait no that's jonathan right yeah oh
okay thank god okay
i got confused i thought it was
churchill joseph for a second sorry but
look how she
he's like collecting the entire jojo
card so eventually he's gonna get to
joseph and i'm gonna be [ __ ] but look
at that that's uh we got jonathan and
dio together like i just i've never seen
this one that's actually really nice
that is really nice never seen this
anywhere i love the like lightning
effect on the figures i love the like
glow it's just so cool the ham one that
looks like it's just everything about
this figure is sick it was 150 bucks but
but again i've never seen this figure
before i thought it was really cool and
i love jojo and everyone knows i love
jojo so yeah it to the collection and
it's a beautiful boy beautiful beautiful
beautiful boy well that's not going to
open because it's like it's a bit more
finicky i mean it's
it's nice i wouldn't say i think you
clearly know that uh tucky is supposed
to be here yeah
yeah to it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be you spend 500 total on
500 total on
now
that that doesn't look worth 250 dollars
i'm not gonna lie the other one i bought
was uh the one that i tried to get as
close to 69 with yeah okay that was one
of the challenges yeah and it is from
one of my favorite games oh [ __ ]
oh
that's nice yeah that is nice i love
okami it's so cute there's a stand for
this as well you come to in the end well
i'll tell you at the end when we when we
try and decide because it should be the
same right for everyone who tried to buy
it
yeah maybe maybe
okay um i guess i have one more um i'll
have one more figure which doesn't have
oh you've got five dollars you want to
go first yeah that's all my ones except
for my last channel oh yeah yeah uh yeah
i got a sebastian michaelis
because it was like the closest to 69.
oh okay okay i guess we'll reveal that
or at the end yeah